talvez o voluntariado seja só um monte
de tretas
todos nós sabemos que a história do
apoio ao desenvolvimento e do apoio
humanitário não é necessariamente uma
história feliz
basta pensarmos no exemplo do haiti do
terremoto que aconteceu em 2010
eu estava no fórum econômico mundial de
davos e enviou 30 dizer um discurso com
intuito de angariar dinheiro para ajudar
as pessoas do haiti
a verdade é que durante aquele período
11 biliões de dólares foram angariados e
depois do terremoto foi de voluntários
todo mundo foram escolha das pessoas do
haiti mas é dura e negra realidade tudo
isto é que apesar de tudo isto é depois
um milhão de pessoas ainda vivem em
tendas
as duas mil e quinhentas pessoas
apenas 5% dos destroços do terremoto que
os 11 bilhões dólares foram goleados 10%
foram investidos na economia do haiti
exemplos como este foram machado da
banda do voluntariado foram machado esse
diálogo humanista de que o ser humano
pode ser um ser realmente altruísta aos
poucos e poucos fomos perdendo a
confiança no voluntariado
de acordo com o inquérito o trabalho
voluntário do instituto nacional de
estatística em 2012 a taxa de
voluntariado nosso país foi o 11 de maio
por cento comparando com a média
europeia é de 24%
e quando falo do voluntariado não falo
apenas do voluntariado que é feita
através de organizações mas o
voluntariado que fazemos informalmente
professores do nosso bairro encontrar
explicações
um em cada 10 em portugal fez
voluntariado
então é um gênio nós questionarmos será
que o voluntariado que realmente importa
é a resposta a esta pergunta não é
simples
talvez o voluntariado não chega de
aumento valor talvez o voluntariado seja
só um conjunto de acções infantis
ingênuos
embora bem intencionada se quem pensa
que consegue mudar muito com pequenas
ações que não são eficazes no longo
prazo talvez o voluntariado gera
desemprego leva as pessoas a trabalhar
de graça
talvez o voluntariado já sofre para
fazer os voluntários sentirem se melhor
e mesmo que seja importante talvez seja
só alguns projovem para os idosos
esses têm tempo e que vão ganhar
créditos
eu sou voluntário desde os 16 anos e
acredito que o voluntariado não tem que
ser nada nada disto e
ao longo de minha vida enquanto
voluntário participa do projeto
transforma seus fundadores do projecto
transformers que é o projeto que usa o
poder das artes do esporte do ipop
mobilizar a nossa juventude em portugal
paula socialmente mais envolvida e foi
enquanto voltar e corria selva amazônica
que tem nas favelas brasileiras
investigados do zimbábue em um mesmo
projeto voltaria diferente então como já
dizia o outro tópico não sou solteiro
tem uma paixão enorme pelo voluntariado
mas também sou economista e isso é
economista de 21 ante e desde essa
altura que também tem estimulado muito
castigado e muito frio do próprio
procurar quantificar de procurar e de
encontrar evidência estatística
realmente justifica o investimento se
gasta recursos que temos e no fundo tem
sido a base dessas duas coisas
essa ação de ser voluntário e esse
esforço por entender que o voluntariado
realmente vale a pena
há certas coisas que gostava de dizer
seu voluntariado que talvez só talvez
não saiba
a primeira é como um feriado geralmente
gera valor econômico e que esse valor
econômico é quantificável a ideia que
não é por um trabalho não será
remunerado que não gera valor como é que
nós fazemos isto é quando você tem uma
forma nós no fundo vamos ver o
equivalente no mercado de trabalho
comemora do do trabalho voluntário seria
moderada do mercado de trabalho
então conseguimos atribuir um valor e
quantificar o valor econômico o
voluntariado e nós fizemos isso hoje
1.800 jovens
fizemos um estudo realizado em israel
1800 jovens do projeto transformers e
conseguimos estimar que nos últimos 12
meses
eles fizeram mais de 68 mil horas de
voluntariado geraram mais de 180 mil
euros valor econômico o que eu acho
fantástico no meio disto tudo é que
nomes como este
no dia 11 os 16
muitos deles nem sequer recebe mesada e
injetar 180 mil euros valor econômico da
nossa economia se numa ferramenta de
participação poderosa o que é
contrariado a mais para além disso não
teria também pode gerar impacto e minha
própria vida é testemunha disso
aos 16 antes de tomar uma decisão
crucial na minha vida eu fazia natação
desde os 4 anos e hoje saí fique bom bom
era seguir um sonho de infância e ir
pago aprender para crianças com amigos
meus
tudo aquilo que eu saí hoje 90% foi
ensinado por amigos meus que montaram
fruta era para me ensinar
agora imaginem que têm falta de
confiança em si próprio
imagine um humilde que não sente bem tem
que se expor
imagine o impacto para este miudo de
aprender algo como isto
vocês não fazem idéia de quantas vezes
nas reservas
mas não é só na transformação individual
que voltaria a ter impacto voltaria
também tem impacto nesse ponto de vista
da exposição coletiva
o melhor exemplo que respostas dar é o
de imunização contra a poliomielite em
meados do século 20 ml todos os anos
paralisada centenas de milhares de
pessoas e hoje em dia a taxa de
incidência do vídeo show mais de 99%
isso foi possível não apenas porque na
década de 50 foi descoberto uma vacina
porque as 10 milhões de voluntários se
mobilizaram e todo mundo pra vacinar
aquela gente toda que fica é se o
voluntariado
eu ia mos tempo estávamos a fazer um
estudo de impacto do projeto transforma
que já falei isso aí é uma pessoa muito
amiga minha que um comentário no
facebook quer dizer grande e gordas do
voluntariado quando há tanta gente sem
emprego estão a trabalhar de graça
se calhar não substituir postos de
trabalho que poderiam estar a ser
remunerado
ao que parece os 27 países da união
européia 27
queremos ver que os países com as
menores taxas de desemprego são também
aqueles que têm menores taxas do
voluntariado
embora curva negativa no emprego
relações de causalidade
este gráfico ainda que dificilmente
desta ideia de que o voluntariado eo
trabalho do brasil não só no tratamento
exclusivo
e precisam um do outro e nós até podemos
ver que em vários aspectos do
desenvolvimento
existe uma correlação entre a taxa do
voluntariado e desenvolvimento de um
país e aqui este quarto ponto
outro mito há quem diga que os
voluntários sentem se deve fazer
voluntariado e tomem cuidado porque nós
não vimos nos sentir vem fazendo uma
coisa que faz as outras pessoas sentirem
discriminados em dar este ponto de que o
voluntariado é criar também não é para
todos
eu acredito que o voluntariado é pra
todos por todo organizado a contribuir e
todos a injeção precisamos da ajuda de
alguma forma humilde eo transforma citou
9 com 12 anos a fazer voluntariado a dar
explicações aos colegas e aos melhores
notas e pessoas com carreiras
completamente estabelecidas que também
são voluntários no projeto e conseguem
conciliar as coisas vão clarear de
aumento para todos
noite preta em isso como todo o trabalho
voluntário é bom que isso não é verdade
acho que é muito importante nós temos
consciência disso nem todos nós podemos
fazer qualquer tipo de trabalho
voluntário
o encontro entre a direcção e menos
jovens que têm um pouco esta missão de
vida de fazer um e pronto está em áfrica
e no sudeste asiático fazer uma missão
de voluntariado internacional e que
acaba por acontecer
dando o exemplo do camboja atualmente os
estados unidos a imensa alunos
americanos que descrevem que foi roubado
o camboja fazer voluntariado em um
orfanato e que tem acontecido é que não
só os mitos da história natural para não
criar relações estáveis porque os
voluntários estão sempre a mudar
com isso criou incentivo para gestores
corruptos alguns orfanatos
manteremos pobres surgem faz porque
pararam que a vontade tem de dar tempo
ele
o curso aos olhos fanáticos que o pior
aspecto pega aquela idéia de que o
voluntariado não é simples nem fácil
é algo complexo e desafiador e que
existe uma paixão para nós irmos à
procura das reais causas dos problemas
uma paixão enorme por prendê los e por
fim no fundo aquilo que acaba por trazer
aqui hoje não é dar uma lição moral
vista realista sobre como é que cada um
deve aplicar o seu tempo entre uma
partida muito honesta porque actualmente
pra mim o trabalho voluntário é
importância
nós vivemos numa época em que consegue
como a solidariedade como o voluntariado
perderam tanto significado perderam
tanto significado pelo seu especializada
pelos corrente descontextualizada que às
vezes chegam a ter conotações negativas
eu acredito que nós temos que envolver a
força e se com site
se não for pelo pragmatismo dos números
que são estreantes
seja pelo voluntariado ao ver ser essa
declaração suprema da dignidade humana e
à dignidade enquanto escolha de onde
queremos gastar o nosso tempo gasto na
operação nossa mãe de uma transação
então nós perdemos a capacidade de ter
os seus livros certeza faltou terminados
dizem que a nossa geração uma geração
perdida de causas e apontar os pedidos
por causas que muitos jovens correm ao
listar suas fileiras do estado islâmico
em busca dessa causa por que dar a vida
eu acredito que nós não perdemos as
causas das causas é que nos poderão
então mesmo que a nossa espera
espero juntar em de importância e
significado e materialização que essa
causa press
nós queremos realmente fazer todos parte
de construção de um mundo radicalmente
mais difícil então não teremos alienada
essa magnífica
desafiadora jornada que é ser voluntário
por uma causa pela qual é nossa vida
vale a pena
obrigado